all right Dina it's been a minute since
we've seen you on TV
I know I'm back to bring the Zen
we've moved to California yeah and yeah
I was surprised almost two years now
you've been out here yeah it'll be two
years in January and what made you want
to pack up and come out I'm not gonna
lie it was my divorce it was just I
wanted to run as far away from possible
as you know what was going on so
obviously that plays into you no longer
being on the show yeah but I imagine
there were other factors that went into
it it really was an emotional decision
it was just like it's not gonna work we
talked you know I didn't Andy and I talk
for a minute about me coming back and
how that would be possible and you know
me living here I do have an apartment
the city but it's not what's not New
Jersey so I'd be one of those people who
are like faking the life right that's
just not me would you ever come back and
do like a cameo well they they had asked
me this season to come to a few things I
was like okay let me see my what my
schedule it allows me to do so if I can
do it great if I can't I'm not gonna
force myself you know felt like it may
happen in the future but you never know
you know I never say never
instead of reality TV Dina is focused on
her new life in LA which includes the
new business and a new man we have a new
beauty line we do glow by Dina and I
teamed up with amazing dermatologists
here in California and we came up with a
formula that's so affordable just leaves
you skin feeling of like silk and it's
amazing and an eye gel can have amazing
glowing bright skin that's healthy
natural looking and that's what I like
is like it you know all this makeup
that's out today with all the other
dramatic contour and everything I feel
bad for the younger generations is just
dating I'm no I'm dating two but it's
four they have to go out there with
these masks on and then what happens
when you make out the mask is all over
your date I think it's like that's not
the chick I saw at the other end of the
dinner table
all right so California lifestyle you're
dating are we so over now I have a phone
okay I shouldn't say anything yes we
live together in
he's great I never thought I would be in
another relationship I was really cool
with just like being on my own I find
you when you're not looking for it
that's what it is and that's what I kind
of want to tell a lot of women out there
who going through especially over 40
divorce is like don't force it it's
gonna come yeah just work on you
you seem you've always been calm but you
seem so relaxed so happy yeah I love
California it's so many it's so sunny I
mean how could you be in a bad mood